madame la
présidente madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la rapporteur générale madamees et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mesdames et
messieurs les
députés nous nous retrouvons ce soir
quelques heures après le rejet de deux
motions de censure pour une raison
simple les mêmes causes produisent
toujours les mêmes
effets prière
cause le REF de trouver des points
d'accord avec nous pour ce projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
comme pour tous les textes depuis un an
et demi les ministres ont mené des
concertations et nous avons tendu la
main aux
oppositions cependant malgré notre
volonté de dialogue aucun groupe
d'opposition n'a souhaité dévier sur de
sa
ligne refuser de voter un budget quel
qu'il
soit
cause le besoin de respecter les délais
constitutionnels pour l'examin des
textes
financiers en commission un débat de
fond a été longuement mené sur le projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale en séance plus de 2200
amendements ont été déposés pour la
seule troème partie du
texte mais le temps imparti pour la
discussion du PLFSS s'achève ce soir
pour que les débats sur le projet de loi
de finance puissent reprendre demain et
malgré ces délais je souhaite que le
texte dont l'examen doit débuter en
commission la semaine prochaine au Sénat
soit enrichi par vos propositions et que
vos amendements puissent y être
[Musique]
intégrés enfin la troisème cause
assurément la plus forte c'est que nous
devons nous doter d'un budget pour
préserver notre modèle social mes chers
collègues s'il vous
plaît ce PLFSS prévoit 640 milliards
d'euros d'investissement pour notre
sécurité sociale des investissements
pour renforcer la prévention pour
améliorer l'accès au soins pour
revaloriser les salaires des soignants
pour recruter davantage de personnel
dans les éepades pour déployer des
solutions concrètes d'accompagnement des
personnes en situation de
handicap pour
multiplier pour multiplier les options
de qualité pour les jeunes enfants ce
sont des avancées pour nos concitoyens
des avancées pour améliorer le quotidien
des
Français et grâce à la discussion
parlementaire nous avons amélioré notre
texte en reprant en reprenant des
amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions au total nous allons
reprendre 250 amendement sans de plus
que l'année
dernière
des amendements pour améliorer la
prévention avec par exemple le dépistage
systématique du comégalovirus chez les
femmes enceintes pour la santé mentale
des jeunes en permettant à la médecine
scolaire de les orienter vers le
dispositif mon soutien MSI pour répondre
à la fragilité des jeunes mamans avec
une expérimentation d'un parcours de
prise en charge de la dépression
postpartum pour améliorer les
allocations au prochédent pour réguler
les activités de dialyse et de
radiothérapie pour faciliter le congé
paternité des agriculteur pour renforcer
la prise en charge du risque
amiante mesdames et messieurs les
députés pourtant en commission les
oppositions ont rejeté le texte dans son
ensemble privant nos concitoyens de
toutes ces avancées pourtant en
commission les oppositions ont rejeté
une nouvelle augmentation massive de 8
milliards d'euros des moyens de la santé
nous devons protéger notre modèle social
nous devons améliorer le quotidien de
nos concitoyens aussi sur le fondement
de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la
Constitution j'engage la responsabilité
de mon gouvernement sur la 3è partie et
l'ensemble du projet doit de financement
de la sécurité sociale pour 2024 je vous
remercie je vous remercie l'assemblée
nationale prend acte de l'engagement de
la responsabilité du gouvernement
conément au disposition de l'article 49
alinéa 3 de la Constitution le texte sur
lequel la première ministre engage la
responsabilité du gouvernement sera
inséré en annexe au compte-rendu de la
présente séance en application de
l'article 155 alinéa 1er du règlement le
débat sur ce texte est immédiatement
suspendu ce texte sera considéré comme
adopté sauf si une motion de censure
déposée avant demain
23h40 et voter dans les conditions
prévues à l'article 49 de la
Constitution dans l'hypothèse ou une
motion de censure serait déposé la
Conférence des Présidents fixera la date
et les modalités de sa discussion
prochaine séance demain à 15h question
au gouvernement seconde partie du projet
loi de finances pour 2024 avec
l'administration générale et
territoriale de l'État sécurité la
séance est
levée